hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my arrow episode 7 video all
about Cupid but I also have some new
pictures for Laurel in her Black Canary
costume and some details on the Flair of
the flash versus arrow crossover so I'm
gonna start with a cupid step first you
may remember her as young Mary
Winchester from Supernatural
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet but starting with top 5 moments
from the episode number 5 cupid
flashback I think the reason they tease
Cupid in the last episode was because
they wanted to open with this flashback
and didn't wanna have to add another
scene explaining who she was
I'm totally a fan of this it means we
can just get right into the action at
the beginning of episodes her origin
story in the show's really close to the
one in the comics few minor changes
Oliver saves her life she develops an
obsession for him it's pretty simple in
the comics she used to be Special Forces
and went through some special
experiments that made her super strong
on the show they made her a former
police officer and she didn't have any
special powers the reason why she was
such a good fighters because all that
police training and presumably she's
been in training since the moment she
picked up that arrow at the end of
season 2 number 4 team arrow vs. team
Cupid was it not creepy how Cupid and
her CI were like this bizarro version of
Oliver and Felicity looks like them
having sex did not end well be
forewarned olicity shippers this Cupid
scene was definitely pointed at you that
whole scene with Oliver explaining about
having to be alone totally a
manufactured Felicity moment
quote-unquote but I thought it totally
worked
she and Oliver just slowly coming to
terms with the reality of their
relationship you have to remember that
they have not really dealt with their
relationship so to speak since the end
of episode 1 the cupid fight scene
totally amazing arrow always has the
best fight choreography so if that's no
surprise
favorite stunt though was why Cupid keep
the great loose and they dropped down
Oliver had to dislocate his own thumb to
get loose from those cuffs every time I
see a character do that in a TV show or
a movie I wince if he ever saw that Vin
Diesel movie pitch black he popped both
of his shoulders out of their sockets
the way they left the character told a
cool the actors teased that she might be
coming back before the end of this
season I mean it'd be the back half of
the season in case you missed it they
totally gave Harley Quinn a shout out
just saying that cupid was replacing the
last woman that they had it kind of
sucks because it makes it sound like
Harley Quinn's never gonna be on arrow
they're making the new Suicide Squad
movie so that might be
why they made that reference it might
just be them saying no we're not gonna
be doing Harley Quinn because the movie
is doing Harley Quinn number three
Oliver and katana team-up we finally get
to see katana in action and get some
backstory
her explanation fits with her comic book
story she didn't really get into great
detail but I expect the show to dedicate
an episode to explain who she and Masayo
were running from in the comics she
doesn't actually become katana like the
superhero katana till after something
really crazy happens and I don't think
the arrow would have cast that character
if they didn't intend on doing that I
don't want to get too crazy with comic
book spoilers but if you know how about
katanas back story in the comics I
expect some of those really big things
to end up happening - the soul blade if
they didn't give Cupid powers I don't
think they're gonna give katana a soul
blade
long story short katana total badass
with a sword cannot wait to see a
character with a sword on Team arrow she
will show up in modern day at some point
so expect her to fight some other
characters that also wield swords number
two Ray Palmer and felicity
this was probably agony for olicity
shippers but let's be real Ray Palmer is
not doing anything wrong he's not a bad
character but he does have an agenda
he's not telling everyone else about the
information about his suit and his
special plans is stored on their servers
so I'm wondering if felicity is going to
discover it at some point or if he's
going to appear to them in costume at
some point Ray Palmer will interact with
team arrow in his atom costume very
special thing getting yourself a shiny
new suit I would say his face in that
scene looks a lot like Felicity when she
got that ten million dollar necklace and
when Roy got his Arsenal costume we can
all laugh about that for a second but
let's talk about the Iron Man suit it's
called an 8000 M exoskeleton at some
point they'll totally explain what that
acronym stands for if you listen
carefully you can hear a new music cue
playing underneath it when they're
revealing the suit
that's his Adam theme like Oliver has an
arrow theme Barry Allen has a flash
theme superheroes get their own theme
music his theme even sounded like it had
a few cues from John Williams Superman
theme which I think is kind of funny
it's just a coincidence that Ray
Palmer's colors are like Superman's
colors but I do like the imagery in the
parallels to his previous work inside
the DC Universe what I'm expecting is
that we'll see the suit teased in
episode 9 he would
be in it we'll just see it in real life
like he'll have finished making it and
my number one moment
Captain Boomerang flair Oh teaser I get
a lot of questions about what Flair Oh
means just to clarify that's the hashtag
for flash versus arrow you really just
see it on Twitter so if any of you
aren't following me on Twitter you can
actually find links with that in the
description the person we saw was the
digger Harkness Captain Boomerang he's
gonna be the villain of the crossover
episodes he actually worked with Manu
Bennett on Spartacus so it's like
they're keeping it in the family both of
those characters were part of the
Suicide Squad so they are gonna do some
Suicide Squad stuff during the crossover
episode the reason they picked him as a
villain is because he's primarily from
the flash comics but he was also part of
the Suicide Squad they're doing Suicide
Squad on arrow so he does he fits better
than most of the other villains they
have in the first part of the crossover
team arrows got to go to Central City to
get information on him then in the
second part of the crossover on arrow
team flash is going to come to Starling
to help take him down so be sure to
watch that that's in two weeks it'll be
Episode eight of both shows outside of
that rainbow Raider supposed to be in
the flash part of the crossover they'll
probably be some other characters in the
arrow side of the crossover it's called
The Brave and the bold so think of it is
like a mini Justice League episode let
me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and here's my
big question for you guys how badly do
you want to punch Thea's douchebag DJ in
the face he could be Roy's new training
dummy just picture Roy doing this on his
face as you can tell I was not a fan of
his character overall I loved the
episode and I loved the way that they
used two episodes to set up the cupid
character it's slightly different than
the way they've done it before they've
done that before in slightly different
ways you know introduced characters and
then turn them into something bigger
later on it's just more evidence that
they're gonna use Cupid in a bigger way
in a future episode
Brandon Roth doing an amazing job so far
playing this hero character who's trying
to be very mysterious keeping all these
secrets if you wondered why he pulled
away from that felicity kiss it's
because he's on the same arc as Oliver
so the reason that Oliver's not with
felicity is the same reason that Ray
Palmer is gonna try and stay away from
Felicity but they're both attracted to
her and who wouldn't be Felicity looks
amazing and is probably the smartest
person you would ever meet I know some
of you might not have warmed up to him
yet but I think we'll get a lot more of
him in the back half of the season
I think the tipping point
is gonna be when that suit hits daylight
like the minute he starts running around
doing extracurricular things inside the
super suit as much as he and Oliver are
loners
they really are family men I think we
just haven't learned a lot about ray
Palmer's family life there's a big
tragedy in his backstory that they're
going to explain in a future episode but
Oliver of course takes himself to
diggle's Diggle is his family so it's
kind of like Lila and Diggle have
adopted Oliver is like a younger brother
Oliver and Roy - I love the way that
they're able to mirror arcs between
characters like they mix and match
things like Oliver and Roy have their
love troubles Oliver and Ray Palmer have
their hero arcs just try to keep your
eyes peeled for stuff like that in
episodes the writers do a really good
job of tying everything together it's
the only thing that I was disappointed
is that they kind of teased a battle
between Cupid and Thea and didn't
deliver on it like she went into the
club I thought she was gonna cause some
trouble so that Thea could show off her
skills
don't worry though that moment is coming
so Black Canary stuff they posted some
new Laurel pics of her in the costume
with the wig on this is somewhere
between episode ten and twelve they
didn't say specifically what they were
filming Caity Lotz made some funny wig
comments she said that her wig her
canary wig was a little more Dolly
Parton and that she liked laurels wig
the straight hair a little bit more but
every time you watch Katie Lots now in
costume in her old episodes just think
of Dolly Parton and laugh a little bit
in addition to that just a good - gal
who plays the Huntress is being screen
tested for the lead in Marvel's Jessica
Jones Netflix series I don't know if
she'll get it because Alexandra Daddario
is also testing and I feel like she's
gonna be the favorite but I'm definitely
rooting for the Huntress that show's
supposed to premiere in late 2015 but
I'll provide some more updates in
separate videos for that I'm also
posting a Q&A for this tomorrow just
like normal so leave all your questions
in the comments so in case you haven't
seen in my other videos YouTube gave me
a new beta feature to test out if you're
watching this on your mobile phone or on
a tablet there are new links that you
can click on up here it's the same as
the links over here which are always
gonna be the same so right now you can
click here to catch up on arrow and
click here to catch up on the flash this
week thank you so much for watching
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you